Welcome back.
In this session we're going to take a
look at our first Ruby Data Structures.
These data structures will allow us to
store more complex and interesting data.
Up until this point we've seen how
we can use variables to store single
pieces of data.
A single number, string, or bullion.
Here's a string variable.
This variable stores a single adorable
puppy named Kareem Abdul Jabark.
He's lonely.
In this session, we'll see how we
can cure our puppy's loneliness
by storing a collection of other dogs,
together in the same variable,
using what's known as an array.
See?
Now he has a couple of friends.
We will also see how we can
use Ruby hashes to store
more detailed information
about each dog.
Dogs are more than just a name.
We can add in an age for each dog.
Let's also give them a breed.
We now have a collection of dogs,
where each dog consists of
multiple pieces of information.
By the end of this session we'll
be able to use Ruby arrays and
hashes to store this type
of complex data in code,
whether we're working with dog data or
real product data.
Let's get started.
Hip, hip, array.